[Música]
Ecuador expulsó al embajador de
Argentina en Quito y lo mismo hizo
Buenos Aires luego de que se conociera
que la ex ministra ecuatoriana de Obras
Públicas mareada y Los Ángeles Duarte
condenada por corrupción se presentó en
la Embajada Argentina en Caracas la ex
funcionaria no contaba con el
salvoconducto necesario para abandonar
territorio ecuatoriano ampliamos desde
quito
la inflación interanual en Argentina
llegó a 102.5 por ciento la más alta en
31 años así lo informó el Instituto
Nacional de estadística Y censos que
además Indicó que en febrero el índice
de precios al consumidor subió un 6,6%
respecto a enero preocupa la subida en
los precios de los alimentos que fue de
9,8%
se cumplieron cinco años del asesinato
de la diputada brasileña María le Franco
un crimen que tras un lustro sigue sin
ser resuelto Este martes familiares y
simpatizantes le rindieron homenaje
Tenemos reporte desde Río de Janeiro
Bienvenidos a esta informativo con las
noticias más relevantes del continente
americano soy Valentina Torres Sánchez y
es un gusto acompañarlos iniciamos en
Ecuador con el caso del ex ministra de
Obras Públicas María de los Ángeles
Duarte pesantes funcionario durante el
gobierno de Rafael Correa el martes se
conoció que se presentó en la Embajada
Argentina en Caracas tras abandonar la
sede diplomática de Argentina en Quito
esto Pese a que el gobierno de Guillermo
lasso le había prohibido la salida del
país previamente conversamos con Gustavo
Ortega corresponsal de France 24 en
Ecuador que nos explicó que reacciones
se han producido en medio de este caso
bueno las principales reacciones han
sido este quiebre entre las relaciones
de ambos países el Ecuador ha declarado
persona no grata al representante
diplomático argentino en este país y ha
dicho que considera que se han vulnerado
los principios de buena fe entre ambos
países la licuadora ha emitido continuas
comunicados durante todo el día de hoy
pidiendo información a Argentina para
conocer Cuáles fueron las condiciones
por las cuales María de los Ángeles
duartes abandonó la sede diplomática
periodo inclusive que Argentina entre
las cámaras de seguridad y los vídeos de
la sede diplomática lo cual Argentina ha
negado esto igual forma también
Argentina ha hecho lo propio ha
convocado a su representante diplomático
y Ecuador también ha llamado a consulta
a su representante diplomático en su
país De igual forma también María de los
Ángeles Duarte ha dicho que Ecuador la
bandería en este país como una rn
política y que a ella la protegía el
derecho de su salvoconducto y el asilo
político
el ente Nacional de estadísticas de
Argentina anunció que la inflación se
elevó Más allá del 100% interanual una
máxima que el país sudamericano no vivía
desde 1991 en este contexto en la región
del Norte y la más pobre del territorio
del incremento fue mayor y los precios
que más subieron fueron los de los
alimentos Ramiro cueva Barberena nos
cuenta más
la crisis económica Argentina sigue
escalando luego de que este martes el
Instituto Nacional de estadísticas y
censo oficializará que la tasa de
inflación anual superó los tres dígitos
por primera vez desde 1991 el índice de
precios al consumidor se elevó el
102,5%, un contexto de compleja
resolución que agota a los ciudadanos No
sí me enteré que es un 100% anual no no
se puede no se puede totalmente
sí que se vayan todos Así estoy cansada
cansada cansada cansada
cansada de todo esto de los políticos de
que se pelean de que y la gente se muere
de hambre según los datos del gobierno
el aumento inflacionario de febrero
alcanzó el 6,6%, un número más alto del
esperado y ya acumula el 13,1% en lo que
va del año en tanto que en las zonas del
Norte las más pobres del territorio el
incremento fue mayor al 7%, los
productos que más subieron su valor
fueron los alimentos y las bebidas otros
síntoma negativo para los sectores más
vulnerables porque no hay nada no hay
plata la gente no tiene Entonces cómo
compra
los otros días Vine le digo Dame dame
tres mandarinas dos naranjas dos banana
y medio kilo de tomate cuando me dijo
650 pesos y que no sacar todo déjamelo
tomate porque no tengo más plata la
inflación es un problema crónico que los
últimos gobiernos no han podido
solucionar pues a sus promesas mientras
para los argentinos el crecimiento
constante de precios sólo significa una
cosa ajustar el bolsillo y estrictamente
necesario vamos a Río de Janeiro porque
se cumplieron cinco años del asesinato
de la diputada brasileña María le Franco
su crimen Todavía no se ha resuelto pero
los habitantes del centro de esta ciudad
decidieron realizar un festival
reivindicativo en su honor Valeria
sacone corresponsal de France 24 nos
trae los detalles
[Aplausos]
[Música]
han pasado cinco años desde que la
concejala negra Mariel y Franco fue
brutalmente asesinada aquí en Río de
Janeiro cinco años después sus
familiares y la sociedad civil se
preguntan Quién fue el mandante de este
asesinato y cuál fue la razón
[Música]
cada día que pasa nuestro dolor aumenta
no conseguimos hacer el luto este luto
del que precisamos después de cinco años
las autoridades de Río de Janeiro tienen
que dar esta respuesta no solo para mí
como madre sino también para los
electores de Mariel la familia y el
Brasil que clama por la justicia social
porque eso es lo que María
[Música]
yo conocí personalmente a Mariel hoy yo
siento que ella me representó de verdad
mucha gente que conozco la conocía la
amaban Yo hoy estoy aquí para apoyar
esta causa para saber Quién mató a
Mariel Franco
tras el cambio de gobierno la policía
fallará abierta una nueva línea de
investigación recordamos que la hermana
de María Eli Daniel y Franco hoy es
ministra de Walter racial en el gobierno
Lula por esta razón la familia espera
ahora obtener respuestas sobre los
autores intelectuales que se ha atentado
y también que por fin se celebre el
juicio contra los únicos dos arrestados
considerados los autores materiales del
asesinato el presidente de Estados
Unidos Joe biden promulgó una nueva
orden ejecutiva que busca aumentar la
verificación de antecedentes para poder
adquirir un arma de fuego la medida
también Busca promover el almacenamiento
seguro de este armamento estas fueron
sus palabras
primero esta orden ejecutiva ayuda a
mantener las armas de fuego lejos de las
manos peligrosas mientras sigo pidiendo
al congreso que exija la comprobación de
antecedentes para todas las ventas de
armas de fuego y mientras tanto mi orden
ejecutiva ordena el fiscal general que
tome todas las medidas legales para
acercarnos lo más posible a la
verificación Universal de antecedentes
sin una nueva legislación es de sentido
común comprobar si alguien es un
delincuente o un abusador doméstico
antes de comprar un arma
y en Ciudad Juárez en México decenas de
migrantes esperan poder llegar a Estados
Unidos después de que el domingo cientos
de personas intentaran cruzar la
frontera masivamente sin éxito ante la
frustración generada por la falta de
atención en el proceso de asilo lanzado
por el presidente Joe biden Alba Santana
nos amplía
frustración y mucho cansancio son los
sentimientos de los migrantes retenidos
en Ciudad Juárez localidad fronteriza
entre México y Estados Unidos yo perdí
todas de los pies míos caminando toda la
selva y todo donde todos lados porque
supuestamente El emigrante no le pueden
dar cola al emigrante no lo pueden
ayudar en ningún lado si emigrar no es
un delito allí muchos pasaron a la noche
en refugios antes de intentar cruzar a
Estados Unidos y acusaron a malos tratos
por parte de las autoridades mexicanas y
falta de protección en general Nosotros
somos seres humanos
lo que procuramos es es este que tengan
vaya que tengan lugar seguro que tengan
un este
un espacio donde donde puedan estar a
salvo todo apenas dos días después de
que cientos de migrantes intentaran
cruzar a la frontera masivamente tras
rumores de que se permitiría su entrada
a suelo estadounidense Pero la realidad
que encontraron o fue muy diferente a la
esperada agentes con escudos abarricadas
Y alambre de Espino
por favor queremos respuestas la
aplicación no nos ha servido para
absolutamente nada la aplicación ya no
da nada viejo
me encuentro
Y es que muchos como Camila Cruz llevan
hasta seis meses esperando una cita para
solicitar asilo en Estados Unidos
acusando que el proceso de asilo que el
presidente Joe biden lanzó en enero
pensado para garantizar la seguridad de
los migrantes tiene carencias la pobreza
y la violencia en sus países de origen
lleva a que unas 200.000 personas
intenten cruzar la frontera hacia
Estados Unidos cada mes es todo por el
momento en France 24 gracias por su
sintonía
[Música]